et direction les états unis où donald
trump se projette vers la présidentielle
prévue fin 2020 4 l'ancien locataire de
la maison blanche était à florence dans
l'arizona hier pour un grand meeting qui
a rassemblé plusieurs milliers de ses
sympathisants l'ancien président qui
bénéficie toujours d'une forte
popularité auprès de ses militants et
son est pris ouvertement à son
successeur de maidan écouter
[Musique]
le parti radical démocrate qui dit
sauver des gens détruit notre pays il
détruit notre pays ça ne fait aucun
doute
nous avons eu plus de problèmes plus de
destructions au cours de l'année écoulée
que lors de cinq mandats réunit
les gens sont persécutés lorsqu'ils
parlent librement des élections truquées
de 2020 mais de plus en plus
d'information arrivent bien plus graves
que toutes celles d'avant
et comme donald trump ses militantes se
sont montrés très critiques envers joe
biden
j'espère qu'il annoncera qu'il se
présente à la présidence en 2024 et puis
aborder les problèmes que nous avons
dans ce pays sitôt politique ratée de
baden j'espère que trump abordera la
crise frontalière l'inflation en cours
la politique étrangère raté le désastre
qui vient de se produire en afghanistan
il ya quelques mois
je pense que joe biden a échoué dans
tout ce qu'il a dit qu'il allait faire
et je pense qu'il a fait de ce pays un
gâchis il prend trop d'argent et le
donne à d'autres personnes se retire de
l'afghanistan laisse tout notre
équipement là-bas laisse certains de nos
gens là bas puis fait venir des afghans
ici et les autorise à rentrer dans notre
pays
donald trump qui aurait encore beaucoup
d'influx ans dans le parti républicain
selon drieu godefridi hauteur et docteur
en philosophie
l'ex-présidente rome s'inscrit dans une
dynamique je dirais de maintenir une
certaine chaleur dans la entre lui et
son électorat et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il continue à organiser ses
meetings qui ont repris assez rapides
donc finalement après l'élection
présidentielle en 2002 ordre et est
généralement il va dans les états qui
ont qui ont joué joueront dans l'avenir
un rôle crucial à au moment de la
prochaine élection présidentielle les
démocrates sont dans une sorte de
politiquement parlant de spirale de mort
haïl sont ils sont ils sont en situation
d'échec finalement total est mis en
échec par des parlementaires démocrates
c'est ça qui vont les chèques d'autant
plus cuisant alors que trump est
effectivement à nouveau dans une vrai
qu'il est dans une position encore plus
forte qu'il ne l'ait jamais été dans le
sens où aujourd'hui il contrôle
véritablement l'ensemble voire la
totalité du parti républicain je pense
que la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
n'est pas de savoir si rome sera
candidat là en 2024 à alexa voir ce qui
pourrait l'empêcher de l'emporter en